messieurs les plombs
sa classe merci pour l'accueil et je
suis heureux d'être à tes côtés
aujourd'hui en roumanie je suis très
heureux en effet d'être tous sur la base
m cas ici à l'invitation de monsieur le
président klaus iohannis ce pour cette
visite aux armées
ce déplacement intervient président
vient de rappeler dans un contexte
extrêmement grave que nous connaissons
tous la guerre d'agression menée par la
russie contre l'ukraine qui se déroule
tout près d'ici
j'ai pu
hier soir ce matin rencontrer les
soldats français qui participe depuis
février à la réassurance de la roumanie
j'ai décidé de ce déploiement le 19
janvier dans son principe pour témoigner
de la pleine solidarité de la france
envers ses alliés européens face aux
menaces sur notre sécurité commune
et je remercie la roumanie d'avoir
accepté que la france prenne la
responsabilité de nation cadre de l'otan
sur son territoire
c'est un signe de confiance le reflet de
l'étroitesse de notre partenariat
stratégique
je veux aussi remercier
nos armées
qui se sont déployés avec une réactivité
inédite entre la décision formelle et la
fin de leur déploiement quelques jours à
peine
ce qui est le signe de la réactivité de
la crédibilité
des armées françaises dans le cadre de
l'otan à l'égard d'un pays ami dès que
la menace survient cette procédure pour
la première fois avait été utilisé et
nous avons montré
vous avez montré
que vous étiez la hauteur et j'en suis
fier et reconnaissant
je sais que c'est d'arriver au mois de
février auront bientôt à retrouver leur
montagne
et je veux à nouveau les remercier et
remercier les successeurs qui
arrivant de castres depuis quelques
jours pour les premiers d'entre eux
viendront les relevés et continueront de
se déployer en tout cas vous dire
monsieur le président que
nous sommes fiers d'être ici
heureux de la mission
qui s'est parfaitement accompli dans
cette première phase heureux de la
poursuivre à vos côtés et aux côtés de
l'ensemble des armées alliées ici
présentes et profite de cette occasion
pour saluer l'ensemble des contingents
et des nations que nous avons croisé à
l'instant et qui permettent de sécuriser
denman
la roumanie ce faisant le flanc oriental
de l'europe et de l'otan et avec
lesquels le travail et quotidien pour
nos soldats
la roumanie n'est pas pour la france un
pays comme les autres
l'alliance entre nos deux pays s'appuie
sur une amitié de deux siècles nous
l'avons évoqué ensemble et à plusieurs
reprises face à des crises mettant en
jeu sa sécurité
la roumanie a pu compter su compter sur
la fraternité de la france et je suis
fier que nous puissions ensemble
prolonger cette histoire
pour aller plus loin nous souhaitons
continuer d'avancer d'abord sur le plan
bilatéral
nous travaillons à la demande des
autorités roumaines à un ambitieux
partenariat de soutien aux forces
navales roues même
gouvernement et nos ministres présents
ont pu s'entretenir
actes et des documents cadres et sur le
plan politique et militaire nous
souhaitons renforcer celui
évidemment ensuite dans le cadre de
l'otan puisque c'est dans ce cadre que
la france est présente sur le territoire
aux mains avec la contribution d'autres
alliés dont je salue la présence un
instant avec bien sûr la pluie des
forces armées romaines le dispositif
actuel va monter en puissance
prochain sommet
que nous serons l'un de l'autre dans
quelques jours à madrid confirmera cette
ambition
c'est une preuve de plus de notre unité
pour écarter toute menace militaire sur
le flanc est de l'union européenne et de
l'otan et puis enfin dans le cadre
européen aussi cette amitié prend une
tournure particulière vous avez rappelé
la communauté de vues qui est la nôtre
monsieur le président quand il s'agit
de la prof politique à l'égard de
l'ukraine
du dossier des balkans occidentaux et
tout particulièrement
des discussions en cours entre
la macédoine nord et la bulgarie et la
présidence française vous le savez y est
tout particulièrement engagée les
prochaines heures seront décisives
qu'il s'agisse aussi
deux accessions à shenzhen nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler je souhaite que
nous puissions avancer sur ce dossier
poursuivre l'effort commun nous menons
depuis tant d'années la france est à vos
côtés et nous fêtons ensemble faire
avancer les choses la boussole
stratégiques que nous avons adoptée a
été
renforcée pour prendre en compte la
menace croissante envers noir elle
illustre pleinement aux préoccupations
nos préoccupations et ce partenariat
et nous sommes engagés avec nos amis
roumains aussi dans le soutien à
l'ukraine sous toutes ses formes
politiques humanitaires financière
militaire parce que là aussi nous
partageons la même condamnation sans
appel de l'agresseur
comme le montre le train sans précédent
de sanctions adoptées par l'union
européenne contre la russie et nous
poursuivons les mêmes efforts pour
assurer notre indépendance énergétique
construire notre défense commune et
ouvrez vous l'avez rappelé un instant
monsieur le président à améliorer aussi
la sécurité alimentaire pas seulement
des européens mais du reste du monde
dans le contexte que nous connaissons
sur tous ces sujets nous avons sens j'ai
pu également et enfin m'entretenir avec
le président hu n'est ni sur la
proposition de communauté politique
européenne
ce que nous souhaitons faire progresser
qui a vocation justement au delà notre
union de nos coopérations bilatérales at
structurée sur le plan politique sur le
plan sécuritaire sur le plan énergétique
et des infrastructures
notre continent et au fond tous les
états qui ont une communauté de
géographie et de valeurs voilà mesdames
et messieurs ce que je souhaitais
rappelé
en disant à nouveau à monsieur le
président chers klaus
l'amitié de la france pour votre pays le
soutien indéfectible
et notre présence dans la durée c'est
d'autant que votre sécurité
sera m'a dit
c'est ça la voilà